qui ne relevait pas de lui donc il nous
a prié de bien vouloir l'excuser
et il arrivera s'il arrive quand il
pourra
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous nous
avons donc le plaisir de disner cet
après-midi monsieur Julien le SETI merci
beaucoup de votre présence monsieur vous
êtes enseignant chercheur à l'académie
militaire de Saint-Cyr couette qui dans
les chercheurs associés l'Institut
français des relations internationales
pour rappel l'académie militaire de
Saint-Cyr Coëtquidan délivre une
formation des livres dispense une
formation initiale pluridisciplinaire de
haut niveau officiers de l'armée de
Terre vous êtes également directeur de
la chair gouvernance du risque cyber au
sein de l'école de management de Rennes
dont on m'invite à préciser que c'est la
reine School of Business ça doit être du
breton
et chercheur au Centre Géode
géopolitique de la data sphère à
l'Université Paris 8 enfin vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques et avait
été chercheurs à l'ifrits comme je l'ai
précisé
vous êtes spécialiste en géopolitique
des technologies vous avez tout
particulièrement travaillé sur la
cybersécurité et les stratégies
numériques des états d'où l'idée de vous
auditionner vous avez publié plusieurs
articles sur la guerre technologique
sino-américaine en étudiant notamment le
cas de l'affaire Huawei que l'affaire
Tik Tok aurait presque réussi à nous
faire oublier Huawei qui est un sujet
que nous avons eu au Sénat l'occasion de
traiter et assez assez régulièrement
cette application est donc aujourd'hui
on le sait le nouvel objet de tension
dans la guerre numérique entre la Chine
et les États-Unis comme nous l'avons vu
auditionner pendant plus de 5 heures le
23 mars dernier par la Chambre des
Représentants américaines le PDG de Tik
Tok a de nouveau contesté les
accusations de contrôle de la société by
dance par Pékin et si la reconnu que les
serveurs chinois des tenaient encore des
données d'utilisateurs américains il a
assuré comme vous l'avez entendu que le
projet Texas réglerait ce problème je
cite d'ici la fin de l'année donc on
sera curieux de vous entendre sur ce que
vous avez pensé notamment de cette
audition votre regard d'expert nous
aidera mieux comprendre d'une part les
menaces que font poser peser des outils
numériques tels que Tik Tok en matière
d'influence ou de collecte de données
mais aussi d'autre part ce qui se joue
dans cette affrontement sino-américain
autour de la plateforme et notamment en
Europe
par ailleurs nous aimerions aussi vous
entendre sur la stratégie européenne
justement à l'égard de l'application
est-ce qu'un front uni se dessine est-ce
que les Européens sont selon vous
capables de peser autant que les
Américains sur Tik Tok nous avons tous
entendu l'annonce qui a été faite par le
ministre chargé du numérique et celui
chargé de la fonction publique à la fin
de la semaine dernière en France je me
donne vous rappeler que cette audition
est captée retransmise en direct sur le
site du ciné avant de vous laisser la
parole pour un exposé liminaire d'une
quinzaine de minutes si ça vous si vous
l'aviez prévu ainsi
nous nous devons de procéder au
formalité d'usage pour les commissions
d'enquête ainsi je vous rappelle qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
je dis toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je le jure Monsieur Merci vous
avez la parole pour votre exposé
linéaire et puis après quoi on aura un
petit jeu de questions réponses pour
permettre de préciser les choses merci
beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrice c'est
évidemment un plaisir à l'honneur d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui pour cette pour
cette audition avec une matière très
dense comme comme vous les souligné donc
mon propos n'a aucune prétention à
l'exhaustivité devant vous je vais
simplement essayer de souligner quelques
quelques points qui qui me semblent
saillants et qui méritent
à approfondissement à la fois de votre
part et aussi des institutions
européennes parce que mon propos va
essayer de se restituer aussi dans une
perspective à la fois intellectuelle et
d'action au plan au plan européen et je
vous propose peut-être de procéder en
trois temps même si les frontières
seront peut-être un peu brouillées de
mon côté avec à la fois d'une part
l'idée de
de démêler cet enjeux TikTok de quoi Tik
Tok est-il le nom aujourd'hui dans les
rapports internationaux avant peut-être
de m'attarder sur le jeu des acteurs
vous avez souligné les différents
initiatives très récentes des Etats-Unis
donc il y a aussi matière évidemment à
s'attarder sur le positionnement de
Washington qui est peut-être plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraît ou du moins
que l'audition récente du PDG Tik Tok ne
laisse paraître mais aussi évidemment de
la Chine et de l'Union européenne et des
États membres bien évidemment et
troisièmement je m'attarderai peut-être
sur un point qui
qui a fait l'objet de quelques débats
épars qui est qui est celui de l'enjeu
des risques et des menaces
cognitives le point était souligné de
façon récente à la fois par la
commission d'enquête il me semble et par
d'autres d'autres observations avec une
difficulté à démêler ce qui
comment dirais-je ce qui ce qui ressort
du du seul produit Tik Tok et du projet
d'influence à plus ou moins à plus ou
moins long terme donc c'est c'est cette
trame que je vous propose évidemment à
présent
vous avez souligné ce rapporteur le
l'enjeu de Huawei il y a quelques années
qui a suscité là aussi des critiques des
débats plus ou moins passionnés à la
fois en Europe évidemment du côté du
côté américain et quand on quand on
resitue ce cette matière TikTok en fait
dans 5 ans 5 ans de sanctions
technologiques et financières
américaines contre les acteurs chinois a
commencé par Huawei pas seulement mais
évidemment le l'entreprise a pris toute
sa part en matière on observe toute la
toute la part prise
par les considérations sécurité sur
l'idée du Doux commerce donc ça c'est
une évolution évidemment majeure en cinq
ans ou ce qui a été pratiqué de la part
de la mission de l'administration de
Trump et de façon d'être plus policée
mais tout aussi résolu sous Joe Biden et
quelque chose de très bien pris en
compte aujourd'hui
ou par ailleurs l'anxiété vis-à-vis de
toute menace potentielle d'interférences
étrangère tantouriste tantôt chinoise
figure là aussi au premier rang des
priorités de politique nationale et
aussi et aussi étrangère
de quoi Tik Tok est-il le nom comme
comme je l'évoquais entré en bulle il
faut bien voir l'esprit à mon sens que
que Tik Tok c'est un objet géopolitique
qui qui est d'un genre particulier
parce que premièrement cet engagé TikTok
vient illustrer à mon avis un hiatus
extrêmement fort en fait entre la
majorité des
usages de l'application qu'on pourrait
qualifier très rapidement de futilité
joyeuse parfois c'est un peu moins
joyeux mais mais globalement il y a
cette idée évidemment de futilité qui
ressort et évidemment le coût de
projecteur géolique que Tik Tok subit
depuis quelques depuis quelques temps et
pas seulement depuis l'année dernière
mais depuis 2019 et ça j'aurai
l'occasion évidemment de le rappeler
parce que il y a eu un enchaînement si
vous voulez de cycles entre le coût de
projecteur porté par Trump lui-même
vis-à-vis Tik Tok en 2019 et la décision
des autorités indiennes en 2020
d'interdire l'application dans un
contexte de rivalité plus ou moins plus
ou moins sourde avec avec Pékin
Tik Tok a été voilà raccroché au wagon
de cette rivalité politique et
stratégique avec avec comment dirais
entre l'un des entraîneurs et la Chine
deuxièmement il faut bien voir l'esprit
aussi c'est cette idée de trajectoire
ascendante en fait et qui est assez
inédite de la part de réseaux social
chinois ça c'est une donnée qui commence
à être bien bien appréhender bien
évidemment c'est tic tac est devenu le
premier réseau social et ce 5 ans après
le lancement de l'application dans sa
version
occidentalisée c'est aujourd'hui
l'application la plus téléchargée au
monde ce qui est le cas depuis 2020 à
une période où effectivement
confinement successifs oblige
ça a pu favoriser évidemment le
téléchargement de cette de cette
application
quand on cherche à se décentrer des des
seuls États ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi de voir que finalement ce succès
Tik Tok qui confirme le pouvoir des
utilisateurs
j'allais dire de vous et de moi mais
c'est pas forcément le cas mais ce
pouvoir défilateur aujourd'hui il se
manifeste de la façon suivante
c'est-à-dire que ce sont eux qui ont
adopté de nouveaux outils qui qui
l'auront été rendus accessibles sans
tenir compte ici des origines
géographiques de l'application et ça
c'est important de prendre en compte
parce que très souvent on a ce tort et
je peux aussi moi-même la voir de se
concentrer sur l'action et la capacité
de réponse de contre-réponses des États
mais les utilisateurs sont aussi parties
prenantes de cette équation TikTok on
peut pas les balayer d'un revers de main
c'est là aussi vous le savez le premier
média social qui est né aux États-Unis
qui est capable de rivaliser très
sérieusement avec les réseaux sociaux de
la Silicon Valley Facebook et ses
filiales Instagram et WhatsApp
paraissent par récit natham il y avait
un échec des projets concurrents vous
avez connaissance du bout du projet de
l'assaut Facebook ou du projet Real
c'est d'Instagram qui tous deux malgré
les moyens qui qui ont été engagés ont
été des échecs donc ce sont deux acteurs
ici qui ont été qui ont été bousculés de
façon de façon plus ou moins vive en à
peine 5 ans donc là ça renvoie aussi au
temps au temps d'action au temps de
l'innovation de l'économie qui ne
concorde pas forcément avec le temps le
temps d'action du politique donc ça
c'est aussi une donnée je pense à
conserver à conserver en tête
c'est aussi un sujet Tik Tok et qui
vient qui vient contester frontalement
l'hégémonie des États-Unis dans le dans
le champ l'économie numérique pardon
tout en envoyant au monde l'image d'une
puissance numérique qui réussit et c'est
là où le cadre de Tik Tok est
intéressant parce que le réseau combine
combine deux modèles d'affaires qui
jusqu'à présent ont fonctionné c'est à
la fois un réseau social et en même
temps une application qui permet de
partager des vidéos et ça jusqu'à
présent
l'exemple montre bien que cette réussite
est pour l'instant pour l'instant
inutile
peut-être plus intéressant d'un point de
vue politique c'est que cette
trajectoire ascendante de Tik Tok vient
éclairer en creux la politique chinoise
de l'administration américaine il s'agit
de sécurité mais il s'agit aussi de
ralentir la conquête technologique de
Pékin et ça c'est une donnée qu'il faut
appréhender évidemment sur le long cours
avec
des prémices que moi je re-situcurer
sous les mandats successifs de Barack
Obama qui avait déjà identifié ces
questions technologiques
alors on y met en pêle-mêle des
questions de représentelle de de
cybersé qui ont figurait vraiment au
cœur de l'agenda bilatéral sinon
américain et ici dans dans cette dans
cette relation entre entre moi et Pékin
il faut bien avoir l'esprit que depuis
une petite dizaine d'années l'idée de le
enfin l'impératif de l'innovation et
peut-être plus flagrant que des
questions d'ordre stratégiques aux
militaire justement dans dans
l'accroissement des tensions entre les
deux acteurs on a des épisodes là aussi
variés successifs depuis une petite
dizaine d'années 1000 accents sur sur
l'IA la soie artificielle épicentre des
des tensions entre entre les deux pays
la 5G évidemment sous Trump avec
évidemment l'affaire Huawei qui en a été
le révélateur parmi parmi d'autres et
aujourd'hui Tik Tok qui vient agréger
toutes ces inquiétudes américaines et
finalement faire monter d'un cran là
aussi cette friction
contrôler entre les deux pays
de façon aussi intéressante et dans le
prolongement l'affaire Huawei que
j'avais le plaisir d'ailleurs de
développer de vendre commission
d'enquête du Sénat il y a 4 ans cette
question Tik Tok est aussi une nouvelle
une nouvelle illustration de
l'instrumentalisation des
interdépendances aujourd'hui économiques
et technologique donc pour rappel c'est
une façon de d'aller affaiblir
l'adversaire par le biais
d'interdépendance économique et
technologique qui ont été tissées entre
entre deux ou plusieurs pays et dans le
cas présent avec Tik Tok Tik Tok et sa
maison mère by dance d'ailleurs un quart
de façon à mon sens très très abouti ces
interdépendances si nos californiennes
qui qui ont fonctionné à plein régime je
dirais depuis 20 ans Biden c'est
immatriculé aux îles Caïmans le pdfik
Tok est singapourien le financement
l'émergence financière de de Tik Tok
c'est fait via des des grands acteurs
comme comme japonais soft banque ou
comme l'Américain KKR
l'ascendant du réseau est aussi été
permise par le rachat de de music hall
Lee qui qui incarnait très bien cette
cette ligne droite je dirais entre
Shanghai et Santa Monica en Californie
et c'est aussi je pense la seule vertu
de la concurrence qui qui a construit le
succès de l'application
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
pour les États-Unis et sans céder à une
lecture un peu psychologisante de la
faire il y a un effet miroir à cette à
cet enjeu Tik Tok vous avez vous avez la
même la même le même procédé d'aller
monétiser à tout crin des acteurs
performants
à même emprunt de la de la culture du
même c'est c'est contenu plus ou moins
esthétiques qui qui ont une dimension
virale
à certains à certains moments de la vie
de la vie internationale donc ça c'est
un point évidemment à mon sens
extrêmement extrêmement majeur et enfin
jamais des débats ont été aussi vifs au
sujet des implications socioculturelles
d'une plateforme numérique on a parlé de
Huawei avec des enjeux peut-être plus
centré sur le hardware bien sûr et là
l'audition des peset Tik Tok la semaine
dernière par le Sénat américain et qui
peuvent preuve flagrante que ce qui
inquiète le législateur américain
allait bien au-delà des des risques en
matière
en matière d'interférence je dirais je
dirais classique
pour basculer sur les jeux les jeux
internes des acteurs je voulais
peut-être m'attarder rapidement sur la
politique américaine qui évidemment
une donnée à suivre de très près avec un
rappel tout d'abord que marcher
américain pour Tik Tok et le plus
important c'est 150 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs donc ça ça
consacre aussi si vous voulez une partie
des succès de l'application
deuxièmement il y a le constat qui est
bi partisan du côté démocrate comme
comme républicain avec du nuance aussi
de part et d'autre qui peuvent se
matérialiser que cette infertik Tok
vient clore de décennies de de quasi
business à yujoal avec la Chine ou les
considérations géopolitiques n'étaient
pas absentes mais elles étaient soumises
au flux au flux humain aux fruits
d'investissement au flux technologique
ça rejoint évidemment mon propos de
départ sur la la remise en cause de ce
doux commerce qui avait été quand même
l'apanage de l'essor de la
mondialisation commerciale et
technologique
une question qui à mon sens se pose de
façon de façon assez nette aujourd'hui
mais les contours de devront être
précisés dans les dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent c'est ce sera la
façon dont dont cette bataille entre les
Américains et TikTok va ou pas ressouder
les big tech les plateformes américaines
derrière le législateur américain
c'est peu probable de manière groupée
mais ça reste possible pour certains de
ces acteurs je pense notamment au groupe
meta qui
dont le dans le PDG max Zuckerberg a
subi c'est 4 ou 5 dernières années plus
plusieurs auditions à ces musclées au
Congrès américain
et président qui a à chaque reprise
mille accents sur la nécessité de ne pas
réguler ou de ne pas démanteler Facebook
ou meta sous peine de favoriser
mécaniquement la tendance et
l'exportation des acteurs chinois mais
la question se pose différemment pour
d'autres acteurs américains par exemple
hier le PDG de d'Apple qui me Cook
louait la relation je cite symbiotique
avec avec la Chine d'Apple avec avec la
Chine donc on perçoit bien évidemment la
dépendance de d'Apple au tissu productif
évidemment qui se trouve qui se trouve
en Chine
bon évidemment extrapoler sans peine
avec avec Tesla qui lui aussi dépend
pour pour une part non négligeable des
capacités de production qui se trouvent
qui se trouve en Chine
donc est-ce que c'est aussi une crainte
de contre-réponses de la part de la part
de Pékin qui qui est qui rejaillit par
ces citations notamment de Tim Cook
c'est possible mais le fait que la
frustration chez certains de ne plus
pouvoir accéder au marché chinois va
certainement peser et va certainement
déclencher des jeunes influence aussi en
bataille rangée du côté du côté des
institutions américaines donc ça ce sera
une donnée à mon sens vraiment vraiment
national pour le coup très très
americanocentré qui sera à suivre dans
les dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent une autre une autre donnée
majeure qui est pour le coup une
considération très politique dans la vie
américaine
dans un contexte où la majorités
politiques sont quand même assez tenues
aux Etats-Unis est-ce que la Maison
Blanche va
aboutir en fait va s'en prendre une
application de façon de façon aussi
ferme qu'il paraît actuellement auprès
qui constituent jusqu'à présent le socle
le socle électoral de l'administration
Biden ça c'est une question dont dans la
réponse est évidemment extrêmement
difficile à apporter de façon de façon
claire mais il en ressort en fait que
l'équation pour le décideur américain
était extrêmement extrêmement complexe
et sensible
vous avez également d'autres
propositions de
régulation ou de d'interdiction au moins
partiel de de la part de députés de
sénateurs américains peut-être un peu
différente du prisme du prisme faucon
par par lesquels on a perçu l'affaire
ces dernières semaines par exemple une
proposition de du camp démocrate de de
ne pas bannir directement TikTok mais
plutôt de prendre la pragmatique dans sa
globalité et d'imposer une sorte de
régulation d'ensemble des réseaux
sociaux et c'est là où la problématique
est intéressante parce que pour nous en
Europe
à travers certaines des régulations sur
certains des textes qui sont les nôtres
rgpd DSA etc on pourrait s'inspirer
évidemment de ce type de démarche et en
profiter avec de gros guillemets pour
pour régler certains des problèmes
majeurs évidemment qui qui ont été
identifiés via les réseaux sociaux
notamment les pratiques de
désinformation ou de circulation des
discours de haine etc
dernièrement dans ce contexte américain
les initiatives les mots qui sont
prononcés actuellement aux États-Unis
illustre assez bien à mon sens se
découplage en marche qui a été qui a été
évoqué analysé de façon de façon assez
détaillée là aussi depuis 4 ans depuis 4
ans Tik Tok peut en être le symbole
peut-être plus abouti que Huawei
et là aussi on a affaire à
une donnée qui viendra certainement
déclencher des contre-réponses de la
part de la part de Pékin quand on quand
on pense par exemple de façon très très
rapide ici de ma part à la dépendance
des des sociétés occidentales
aux cellules de batterie aux éléments de
panneaux solaires aux approvisionnements
lithium raffinés tous ces produits dans
lesquels les acteurs chinois ont des
parts de marché extrêmement extrêmement
fortes et bien vous vous prenez ces
trois enjeux là vous avez des éléments
de contre-réponses de la part de Pékin
qui pourrait très bien survenir en étant
très en poussant la logique un peu un
peu au bout qui pourrait venir assez
assez clairement ce matérialiser
côté chinois à l'inverse vous avez
d'autres questions évidemment qui se qui
se posent le fait que que l'application
sinisée douille l'équivalent
l'équivalent de Tik Tok pour le marché
chinois soit configuré différemment en
Chine même de telle sorte qu'elle ne
soit pas utilisée à des fins
contestataires
à mon sens ça donne assez logiquement
corps aux arguments qui vont avancer que
il y a il y aurait une stratégie
chinoise pour aller
à minima diviser sinon à bêtises
le fait que ici il ne faut pas confirmer
leur jeu Tik Tok à travers ce prixme ce
prisme cognitif comme comme étant propre
à la jeunesse occidentale vous avez des
initiatives aussi qui se produisent en
Inde je l'ai rappelé dès 2020 mais aussi
une interdiction plus récente de
l'application en Jordanie et des
discussions chez vos homologues
égyptiens actuellement pour pour
interdire l'usage de l'application donc
il faut peut-être aussi
faire un effort pour essayer de
décentrer notre regard parce qu'il y a
une tentation là aussi il faut forcément
très très rapide d'aller concentrer
l'analyse c'est ce qui est fait aux
États-Unis sur ce périmètre se périmètre
occidental donc avoir une lecture
globale je pense qui qui serait
peut-être plus utile pour
en termes d'actions politiques
autre données aussi à mon sens
intéressantes dans le cas de la Chine
c'est que en 2020 quand Donald Trump
faisait pression pour pour aller vendre
les activités de pour imposer une vente
aux activités TikTok aux États-Unis la
Chine ajoute un nouveau catalogue de
contrôle des exportations qui qui
répertoriait de façon implicite les
algorithmes comme étant des éléments
contrôlés donc comme des éléments
extrêmement sensibles vis-à-vis desquels
il fallait avoir une position comment
dirais une politique de de rétention et
de considérer de façon de façon analogue
au code source de tels de tels services
ou applications par exemple
donc ça c'est une donnée aussi
importante parce que ça montre bien que
le décideur chinois a aussi anticipé
certaines des réponses et certaines des
actions du côté du côté de Washington
sur un plan international et ça c'est un
point sur lequel je me permets
d'insister
cette affaire TikTok pourrait rester
paradoxalement jouer en faveur des
intérêts chinois de politique étrangères
parce que pour Pékin le raidissement
américain il vient confirmer ce qui a
été ce qui a été perçu du côté chinois
mais aussi dans d'autres dans d'autres
coins du monde comme étant des doubles
standards américains en matière de libre
circulation l'information ou de libre
circulation des données
et ici le fait d'un éventuellement
d'interdiatik Tok viendrait affaiblir ce
magistère moral des Américains qui
sous-traintent avaient déjà été
passablement accordée en matière
technologique je me suis uniquement sur
cette sur cet aspect technologique et
numérique
et ici en terme politique la difficulté
pour les Américains serait justement
d'aller continuer d'aller continuer à
porter
cette cette position traditionnelle de
garant de la livre circulation des
données d'information et ça c'est
extrêmement délicat parce que c'est un
enjeu qui qui structure en bonne partie
la propre diplomatie américaine du
numérique et qui retranscrit dans de la
plupart un des grands textes américains
et qui va structurer ensuite en bonne
partie les les différentes Task Force et
groupes d'intérêts qui vont ensuite
porter la position américaine dans le
dans le reste du monde bon ça c'est une
donnée peut-être davantage d'ordre
diplomatique mais qu'il faut prendre je
pense très au sérieux surtout dans un
contexte actuel autour de la guerre en
Ukraine ou c'est ces batailles de récits
prennent tout leur importance
avant de m'attarder sur la peut-être de
chlore sur la posture européenne et sur
les réactions possibles du côté européen
je voulais revenir sur cette idée de de
menace cognitive parce que le terme est
un peu est un peu à la mode il a fait
florest tout récemment dans certaines
des observations qui ont qui ont pu être
publiés ou émises
et si je voulais faire juste quelques
constats préliminaires
d'abord le cas de le cas de Tik Tok
évidemment en termes de d'accès aux
données voire de pêche au chalut
numérique n'est pas n'est pas isolé ce
qui est particulier c'est vraiment la le
vivier d'utilisateur du Tik Tok pour
rappel c'est un milliard 7
d'utilisateurs une donnée purement
numérique qu'il faut aussi avoir à
l'esprit deuxièmement c'est ce que
TikTok est une est une des rares
plateformes jusqu'à présent à ne pas
recourir massivement à des publicités
cibler dans son modèle économique
précise et troisièmement Tik Tok est
bien plus qu'un forum entre guillemets
c'est aussi un éditeur du contenu donc
ça aussi évidemment c'est c'est ce qui
peut déclencher toute la toute la
susceptibilité et l'anxiété je dirais
des législateurs
plus largement ce qui vient ici appuyer
mon mon propos sur sur ces différentes
formes de menaces de nature cognitive
c'est que
l'entremêlement là aussi
l'interdépendance de tous les réseaux
médiatiques et numérique
fond de cette suprématie
narrative informationnelle un enjeu qui
est extrêmement éminent de ces
interdépendances aussi politiques et
technologiques à la fois globale mais
aussi pris dans leurs dimensions plus
localisée entre États-Unis Chine entre
l'Union européenne et la Chine entre
l'Union européenne et la Russie par
exemple donc ça on le voit tout
particulièrement depuis février 2022 et
la guerre et la guerre en Ukraine
aussi très bien par ailleurs c'est que
toute la toute la toute la grammaire
stratégique de la subversion elle est
remise au goût du jour par l'évolution
des technologies et ce qui vient appuyer
cette cette idée avec Tik Tok c'est que
c'est que l'IA a pris une nouvelle
importance en permettant d'aller
potentiellement personnaliser plus
finement les manipulations d'information
pour idéalement à terme atteindre un
plus grand nombre d'individus
et ici cette interdépendance cognitive
entre les sociétés a aussi permis le
développement voire même le foisonnement
d'un mercenarian influence numérique
dont les effets restent assez délicat à
contrer on l'a bien vu dans l'actualité
récente avec les révélations autour de
Tim Georges etc car c'est c'est
manipulations feront très souvent
intervenir des intermédiaires des
proxises qui sont qui sont éthiques donc
on est aussi face à des à des des
comment dirais-je des déni de
responsabilités ou habillement des
actions dissimulées plus ou moins
clandestine dans ce champ international
donc Tik Tok peut aussi servir à ce type
de stratégie
qui je leur répète encore une fois et
extrêmement difficile à contrer sur le
sur l'instant et évidemment évidemment à
plus long terme dans des campagnes
d'influence qui qui durent bien au-delà
de cycles de crise de contestation
politique par exemple
donc ça c'est un point je pense
important même si pour en revenir à
TikTok plus plus qu'en cherchant à
influencer directement Tic-Toc avec son
algorithme peut peut simplement ne pas
recommander un contenu peut-être le
contenu est-ce qu'il va façonner en
retour la consommation des utilisateurs
de l'application
et ça c'est quelque chose qui a été très
documenté notamment pour pour éviter de
faire ressortir dans les recommandations
de contenu vidéo toutes les
problématiques liées liées à ce que
Monsieur Charron avait je crois évoqué
la semaine dernière devant vous autour
des des différentes des différentes
questions qui qui suscitent lire du
parti état en Chine
il faut bien comprendre je pense quand
on aborde c'est ces questions là que ce
que j'évoquais en termes de subversion
est devenu la norme dans les relations
internationales je vais je vais venir à
la fin plutôt que l'exception finalement
donc cette idée de finalement de rapport
de force dans dans le domaine cognitif
vient exploiter quelque chose qui est
assez ancien donc c'est aussi au fond
une sorte de ressaque qui qui nous
revient le ressac d’opération influence
au long cours mais adapté à des contenus
extrêmement personnalisés avec aussi
l'idée de répétition parce que ce qui
est aussi propre à l'usage de type de
Tik Tok c'est cette c'est cette c'est
non seulement la durée extrêmement brève
des contenus mais aussi la répétition
qui qui permettent
qui permettent justement d'aller capter
l'attention d'aller capter l'attention
de l'utilisateur et le rendre évidemment
extrêmement dépendant des contenus qu'il
consulte
pour en venir à Mani européenne et puis
je finis avec ce point là
[Musique]
je dirais très rapidement que c'est une
chose d'aller prendre des mesures pour
restreindre TikTok dans la communauté
des fonctionnaires européens à la
commission Parlement etc et c'en est une
autre évidemment d'aller décider au sein
des tests membres d'interdire
l'application ça poserait évidemment
d'évidents problèmes en matière de de
liberté d'expression et après six ans
évidemment le précédent de RT ou de
Spoutnik l'année dernière mais il faut
des raisons graves des raisons étayées
pour invoquer une telle décision donc là
il y a évidemment une un questionnement
d'ordre politique qui est extrêmement
extrêmement sensible dont les contextes
qui est le nôtre en terme en terme
stratégique l'autre l'autre enjeu pour
les Européens c'est celui qui est aussi
le nôtre je dirais par rapport par
rapport resserrement des relations
atlantiques depuis la guerre enfin
depuis février 2022
il y a le constat à faire des vastes des
efforts diplomatiques
américains pardon pour renforcer les
alliances associant à la fois européen
et certains pays d'Asie notamment le
Japon la Corée du Sud de Taïwan et quand
on prend la séquence récente notamment
avec le formules avec la conférence de
la sécurité de Munich en février et
dernièrement le le Mobile Congress de de
Barcelone les la structuration
d'initiatives américaines a été
extrêmement bien huilé et le but était
simple en fait il s'agissait d'aller
inciter les partenaires européens et
asiatiques d'aller rejoindre la position
la position américaine au sujet de Tik
Tok en particulier et plus largement au
sujet des acteurs technologiques chinois
ce qui est aussi à suivre et puis c'est
mon point de conclusion là aussi en
faisant un lien avec l'idée de menace
cognitive c'est que
les institutions européennes ne parlent
pas de zéro vous avez le service
européen en action extérieur le SEAE qui
a qui a entrepris des travaux des
réflexions depuis depuis quelques années
ça s'est renforcé intensifié depuis
quelques mois au sujet notamment de la
sécurité cognitive tout ça dans le cadre
de la stratégie de réponse aux menaces
informationnelle et d'interférences
étrangère donc s'il y a s'il y a aussi
une réponse à apporter autre que le
bannissement de Tik Tok allez chez
l'européenne ce serait aussi d'aller
étudier en profondeur en y associerant
différentes formes d'expertises à la
fois politique de chercheurs ou autre
d'aller voir justement les effets
potentiels de cette application sur
justement sur différents types
d'audience en partant de cette de cette
expertise structurée au sein du SEAE et
puis dernièrement ce qui est aussi je
pense important pour pour nous européens
c'est d'élargir la focale c'est-à-dire
que vous avez un lien à mon sens entre
la problématique technologique
énergétique et militaire
je prends un exemple tiré de l'actualité
immédiate vous avez en Norvège un
industriel de l'armement qui s'appelle
Namo qui ne peut pas agrandir une usine
de production de munitions censé livrer
notamment l'Ukraine parce que des data
centers qui sont utilisés par TikTok
consomme tout la production électrique
de la région concernée donc ce qui a
fait dire d'ailleurs au PDG de cette de
cette société norvégienne que que la
croissance d'entreprise était entravée
par le stockage de vidéos de chatons bon
l'allusion est un peu triviale mais ça
montre bien que dans dans la perspective
des intérêts européens vous avez vous
avez une équation là aussi à plusieurs à
plusieurs données qui rend qui rend la
chose très complexe entre entre la
comment dirais-je le la montée en gamme
du soutien l'Ukraine quand la guerre
conventionnelle revient sur le sur le
continent entre la problématique
énergétique qui pose là aussi des défis
existentiels pour évidemment les
Européens et en même temps cette cette
action à prendre vis-à-vis d'acteurs
extra-européens qui qui pose certains
types de défis et de risque que j'ai pu
évoquer succinctement je vous remercie
beaucoup
je vous remercie on aura les uns les
autres quelques questions à vous poser
je passe directement l'apport à monsieur
le rapporteur s'il a des questions parce
qu'il a
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup de cette intervention
complète et détaillée
je voudrais commencer par m'excuser
évidemment je suis très en retard j'ai
appris hier soir hier soir tard que
j'étais non pas invité mais presque
convoqué à une réunion un déjeuner à
l'Elysée en présence de tous les
présidents de groupe enfin d'un certain
nombre de présidents de groupe et par
conséquent c'était difficile de
refuser j'ai pas voulu demander à Marc
porcelier de de reculer l'heure de cette
réunion parce que ça aurait été beaucoup
plus compliqué pour tout le monde que de
la laisser et puis de
et que je sois le seul en retard mais je
voudrais m'excuser auprès de vous
d'être en retard cet après-midi
je voudrais vous avez déjà répondu à
beaucoup des questions que nous nous
posons je voudrais vous en poser
peut-être deux ou trois autres et puis
ensuite
mes collègues le feront à leur tour
la première c'est pensez-vous que le
projet Texas c'est-à-dire le projet qui
fait en sorte qu'on racle soit demain la
société qui
gère les serveurs et un certain nombre
de services de la plateforme
soit crédible
c'est à dire en l'occurrence
qu'elle peut éviter et contrôler qu'il
n'y ait aucune porte dérobée qui arrive
directement
impeccable Shanghai ou ailleurs ou à
Singapour ce qui serait peut-être moins
grave
la deuxième question c'est en
interdisant et en le faisant brusquement
et avec
urgence avec un faible délai en
interdisant
à tous ces fonctionnaires
le chargement de l'application Tik Tok
la Commission Européenne
j'ai l'habitude de dire a ouvert une
boîte de Pandore parce que si c'est vrai
pour la commission c'est vrai pour le
Parlement aussi qu'il a décidé c'est
vrai évidemment pour tous les
gouvernements européens d'ailleurs ils
continuent à
s'en rendre compte et le deuxièmement
c'est vrai également bien au-delà c'est
vrai pour des entreprises pour des
employés cadres ou autres de
d'entreprises stratégiques c'est vrai
pour beaucoup beaucoup de monde
et en même temps la Commission
européenne ne donne pas de
de raison c'est à dire elle dit crainte
de transfert des données bon est-ce que
c'est pour éviter les problèmes
diplomatiques avec la Chine et ne pas
directement dire c'est pour éviter
lesionnages chinois mais il n'empêche
que il n'en reste pas moins que si elle
fait ça c'est qu'elle a des bonnes
raisons c'est rare que la Commission
européenne demande qu'on agisse dans les
15 jours
est-ce que vous avez des informations
plus précises évidemment on va le on va
poser la question à la Commission
européenne quand on les additionnera
mais peut-être vous avez des
informations plus précises
la troisième question qui est beaucoup
plus générale et pas seulement qui
concerne pas seulement TikTok est-ce que
selon vous le le
règlement européen sur les services
numériques le DMA le DSA
sont aujourd'hui
la garantie d'une véritable
responsabilisation des plateformes ou
est-ce que l'objectif est encore loin
loin d'être atteint
et enfin
quel est votre
bien entendu le problème vous avez
évoqué l'interdiction on n'est pas dans
cette commission d'enquête aujourd'hui
sur une proposition je donne une
décision de proposition de quoi que ce
soit peut-être qu'à la fin on aura un
certain nombre de recommandations
peut-être même en raison de choses qu'on
découvrait que ça pourrait être le sujet
de l'interdiction mais indépendamment de
cela
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on peut continuer à
votre avis est-ce qu'on peut continuer
est-ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose au
fait que les gafam sont interdits en
Chine sont interdits en Russie ailleurs
et au fait que de l'autre côté on laisse
la Chine la Russie faire ce qu'ils
veulent sur les gafams toute la
désinformation les fake news etc et
gérer Tic-Toc de la façon de la façon
dont ils veulent avec éventuellement les
soupçons d'espionnage
dans cette
confrontation géopolitique qui ne fait
que qui va nous faire qu'augmenter au
cours des des années qui viennent
comment sortir de cette contradiction
merci
il y a pas mal de questions on va
peut-être faire une première salle de
réponse là-dessus
avec le micro alors
les questions sont assez sont assez
diverses donc je non plus pas de
prétention d'exhaustivité mais je vais
essayer d'être le plus le plus précis
possible en prenant peut-être pour pour
point de départ votre dernière question
sur sur finalement ce que
évoquant pas le terme de réciprocité
mais c'est bien ici film au fond l'enjeu
et que je re situe dans ce que j'ai pu
évoquer avant votre arrivée au sujet des
interdépendances qui qui sont
instrumentalisées de part et d'autre
entre les grandes puissances et les
grands les grands acteurs dans le champ
dans le champ technologique donc là
c'est vrai que je j'aurais tendance
rapidement à lire la question aussi à
des enjeux d'identité de savoir qui nous
sommes et ce qu'au fond on applique
toujours l'enjeu des valeurs quand on
quand on cherche à défendre un modèle
technologique ou alors est-ce que moi
lorsqu'on assume le fait que tous ces
angles technologiques soient devenus des
enjeux de sécurité nationale et ce qu'on
se débarrasse de ces oripos qui qui dans
le cas des États-Unis on a bien vu
récemment peuvent embarrasser des
actions embarrassées d'action politique
mais ça ça peut faire plusieurs retours
le risque de fragmentation technologique
qui évidemment n'est pas n'est pas
nouveau il a été identifié déjà plus
plus de décennie qui est pratiqué de
façon originale par la Chine dans l'art
structuration même de son propre
cyberespace mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui avec certaines des actions
occidentales on a quand même
l'impression d'un détricotage non
seulement des interdépendances mais
aussi de ce qu'ils font aussi la nature
ouverte libre interopérable de du réseau
donc c'est au fond ma réponse ici elle
vient vous dire que c'est à faire de de
choix très politique en fait sur ce
qu'on souhaite aussi véhiculer et
transmettre par par le biais de la
technologie donc c'est évidemment une
question une question une question
épineuse et le fait de vivre dans un
contexte de réciprocité certes est assez
est assez tentant
ce fameux terme de de webpolisations en
anglais qui illustre bien finalement
toutes les balles tirées dans dans ces
aspects là mais qui auraient aussi pour
effet de créer des situations d'escalade
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure les
différents domaines dans lesquels la
Chine pourrait éventuellement répliquer
les batteries le lithium les panneaux
solaires etc ou là on voit bien que il y
a une forme d'asymétrie par rapport à
par rapport à ce qu'ils font une partie
de nos ressources économiques donc c'est
évidemment très très sensible
sur en remontant le fil de vos questions
vous avez évoqué vous avez évoqué le
l'appareil digitatif dans ces dotés
l'Union européenne
est-ce qu'il est suffisant c'est vrai
que quand on prend le rgpd le DSA plus
récent quand on prend aussi j'y ajoute
volontairement les
la capacité d'action est parfois la
volonté de d'action de certaines
techniques européennes on voit bien que
finalement cette appareillage européen
est déjà assez et déjà assez conséquent
qu'il y a un foisonnement de
d'initiative aussi en matière de de
cybersécurité depuis une année de lutte
aussi contre des informations qui est
qui est louable il faut pas c'est des à
cette idée je pense d'Union européenne
qui qui serait nécessairement une
passoire et qui aurait nécessairement un
temps de retard par rapport par rapport
au temps de la technologie donc il faut
aussi je pense se fait citer de de cette
cet appareil donc ça veut dire aussi par
extension que il faut l'Union européenne
puisse puisse tirer profit de cette
puissance normative et comme elle l'a
montré dans le cas du du bannissement de
TikTok dans les appareils des
fonctionnaires européens de la
commission
qu'elle puisse agir rapidement vous avez
souligné le délai de 15 jours ce qui est
évidemment dans dans le temps bruxellois
extrêmement réduit donc il faudrait
aussi être en mesure de proposer des
disatives tout aussi tout aussi réduite
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
temporel
je ferai un parallèle quand vous
évoquiez le le manque de justification
donnée à cette interdiction au sein de
la Commission européenne sans parler
avec la boîte à outils 5G qui avait été
qui avait été annoncé au plus fort des
tensions avec Huawei il y a quelques
années
en 2000 si même en est bonne et qui déjà
à l'époque avait été un signe politique
assez fort de la part de la commission
dont on n'avait pas forcément l'habitude
de voir la prise en compte politique de
cette thématique de sécurité mais en
même temps cette boîte à outils 5G ne
tranchez rien c'était essentiellement
des propositions des préconisations qui
étaient faites aux États membres mais
évidemment qui qui se voyait totalement
libre pour pour ensuite agir sur le plan
de la loi en interne donc est-ce que la
est-ce que là le parallèle est
satisfaisant avec avec Tik Tok
totalement certain mais ça peut être
aussi assez tentant finalement de de
dresser une continuité entre ce qu'il y
a ce qui a sucé l'intérêt du législateur
européen à cette époque en
2019-2020 pardon et aujourd'hui avec
avec les différents regards des
institutions européennes sur sur ces
sujets et pour aborder la question
de du projet Texas et aussi du projet
finalement Clover qui est une émanation
finalement européenne de cette
initiative européenne ce que je vois
avant tout ici c'est le retour en fort
de de l'enjeu de la relocalisation des
données donc on avait pris conscience il
y a exactement 10 ans en fait avec avec
la personne c'est en jeu d'aller
relocaliser les données numériques sur
des territoires donnés avaient à
l'époque été critiquée vertement par les
Américains qui nous avait accusés de
protectionnisme déguisé donc là c'est
c'est assez cocasse que que finalement
les États-Unis se livrent ou se
livrerait à l'avenir de manière proche à
des pratiques plus ou moins similaires
et qui reviennent à
imposer de facto protectionnisme très
marqué en matière de de stockage des
données donc est-ce que ça revient à
dire que pour pour les Européens il y
aurait davantage de coups des franges en
la matière je ne sais pas mais
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
politique ce serait aussi évidemment
évidemment à suivre d'un point de vue
technique je n'ai pas toutes les toutes
les cartes en main mais ce qui est ce
qui est soulevé à travers cette
cette relocalisation des données des
utilisateurs pardon américain de Tik Tok
aux États-Unis ce serait aussi la
capacité de l'entreprise à pouvoir
assurer vraiment cette cette scission
des activités sachant qu'une partie des
déséquilibres techniques se situe
toujours en Chine donc dépend aussi
formellement de la de la loi chinoise
donc ça c'est une une donnée qui est
peut-être moins souvent évoquée quand on
évoque Texas eclover mais qui méritera
aussi une clarification je pense de Tik
Tok et de la maison mère bike dance et
là la réponse évidemment majeure
j'aurais une petite question avant de
prendre les questions des personnes
inscrites alors je me fais pas l'avocat
du diable en disant ça mais c'est pour
vous faire préciser les choses
tout au long de votre votre propos
liminaire vous avez évoqué les
difficultés qu'on rencontre enfin qui
peuvent être provoqués par TikTok mais
vous avez insisté un moment pour dire
que la particularité de TikTok c'était
le vivier d'utilisateur du fait du
nombre d'abonnés qui a été
exponentielles et qui est énorme par
rapport à des réseaux qui sont arrivés à
saturation ou comme Facebook dont on
nous dit que c'est entre guillemets et
un réseau vieillissant
l'absence de publicité ciblée le fait
qu'il soit éditeur de contenu mais dans
tout ce que vous avez évoqué depuis le
début vous n'évoquez pas enfin j'ai le
sentiment alors soit c'est parce que ça
va sans dire et donc je voulais vous le
faire préciser soit ça c'est parce que
c'est le fond de votre pensée vous
n'évoquez pas de différence de nature
profonde avec d'autres réseaux sociaux
vous venez même de dire que finalement
les États-Unis se retrouvent un peu dans
une position
quand il exigent ils exigent où ils
demandent la localisation des données
après s'être offusqué du fait qu'on
pouvait le demander à une époque vous
avez dit à un moment que une des
particularités de Tik Tok était par
exemple le fait un peu subtilement de ne
pas recommander certains éléments plutôt
que de recommander de manière un peu
grossière mais dans ce cas c'est un peu
la même chose avec Cambridge Analytica
ou ce qui est sorti des différentes
notamment les commissions d'enquête
parlementaires c'était le fait de
réussir à dégouter des dissuader d'aller
voter plutôt que de faire voter pour
celui d'en face on a eu ça dans certains
comtés très précis donc la question
c'est est-ce que vous vous confirmez une
différence de nature profonde qui tient
qui tient au régime politique
de la maison dans lequel se situe la
maison mère premier point et deuxième
point par rapport à Huawei vous avez dit
que le parallèle était pas forcément
évident à faire mais finalement si on ne
parle pas interdiction générale et
absolue ce qui poserait une différence
une une difficulté de positionnement par
rapport à l'Occident et son rapport aux
libertés publiques à la liberté
d'expression etc
est-ce que le parallèle avec Huawei ne
peut pas être fait sur des interdictions
plutôt des freins ou des limitations ou
le fait de brider sans mauvais jeu de
mots de manière ciblée par exemple ce
qu'on fait en France sur le fait de ne
pas interdire les équipements Huawei
mais de dire où sont les endroits où on
ne peut pas mettre des équipements
Huawei que ce soit sur l'investissement
en dur sur le logiciel
puis je vous laisse peut-être noter ça
et je prends les autres questions à ce
moment-là si ça vous permet de faire une
réponse groupée monsieur Perrin
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le Président ah
pardon
non non peu importe
sur l'égalité
j'ai pris dans l'ordre
ah bah pas le savoir à l'avance madame
billon je vous en prie pardon monsieur
le Président mais le regard était dans
la même direction donc merci à vous
monsieur nosettides pour déjà toutes les
réponses que vous a pu vous avez pu nous
apporter
vous avez évidemment dressé le tableau
de l'application Tik Tok avec cette
application au départ jeûne lui dit que
et qui devient finalement source
d'utilisation de de guerre géopolitique
l'occasion pour Pékin de d'attaquer
finalement de dénoncer la censure
occidentale donc ne pensez-vous pas que
finalement cette censure qui intervient
après des années de d'utilisation de
réseaux sociaux autre que finalement
chinois
soit de nature à affaiblir finalement
les démocraties
occidentales ou le modèle américain
parce que la caparation des des données
le pompage des données c'est pas nouveau
donc qu'est-ce qui justifie aujourd'hui
cette ça a été déjà posé par nos
collègues mais c'est ces inquiétudes
n'auraient-elles déjà pas dû avoir lieu
depuis plusieurs années et finalement se
flécharge de la Chine n'est pas n'est-il
pas de nature à nous affaiblir juste sur
la législation que vous appeliez de vos
vœux et que vous faisiez référence au
rgpd au DSA qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner comme piste à quelle échelle
avec quel réciprocité parce qu'on a
surtout parlé de l'Europe pour l'instant
et ne pensez-vous pas qu'un réseau qui
compte plus d'un milliard presque deux
milliards d'utilisateurs est-il encore
possible de l'encadrer merci j'espère
que mon collègue
André gatolin n'a pas été absorbé sa
question n'a pas été absorbée c'est
l'amour c'est de regarder la même
direction je suis in absorbable j'ai
toujours une question de
rechange voilà non moi je reste un peu
sur ma faim parce que c'est la question
que je me pose vous avez dû me
l'entendre poser d'ailleurs dans une
précédente audition de quoi Tik Tok
est-il le nom et là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est sur quelque chose encore dans
l'analyse à tous les niveaux au niveau
de cette commission et de vos propos
un peu flou moi ce que je me demande
c'est est-ce que c'est une entreprise
classique si oui quel est son business
model actuel et quel est son devenir
je dis ça parce que vous avez vous-même
vous dites c'est un réseau social qui a
un milliard
700 millions de
d'utilisateurs c'est une source de
données incroyable et on ne fait pas de
publicité ciblée quand je regarde les
résultats économiques de Tik Tok en
évolution bien sûr il y a une croissance
mais ils sont très inférieurs à ceux
d'autres réseaux américains comme
snapchat beaucoup moins puissant
quand je vois le nombre de données qui
sont maniés quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une évaporation
nos services comme ça que nos services
d'intelligence qualifient les choses de
centaines de milliers de millions de
données personnelles sur le territoire
français c'est à dire que il y a pas
c'est pas les accords russes qui vont
casser un système mais tout d'un coup on
se rend compte que la Caisse Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie de tel département
s'est fait voler ses données il y a un
intérêt pour la Chine qui développe un
modèle intelligence artificielle fondée
sur le nombre et ce qu'on appelle le
Deep learning le machine learning je
vois pas pourquoi Pékin se priverait de
cette capacité de Denner et respecterait
la non utilisation ou la non
revendication de ces données quand je
vois que Tik Tok annonce que plus de la
moitié de ses futurs bénéfices sur le
rond là pour alors est-ce que ça sera
fait pour rétribuer les producteurs de
contenu donc c'est un modèle économique
je me dis mais c'est fou alors je veux
bien croire que le capitalisme chinois
d'y faire singulièrement du capitalisme
occidental mais je peux je ne peux
m'empêcher d'y voir un dessin et un
projet beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus obscur en termes de captation de
données en termes d'influence
généralisée notamment sur une génération
grandissante et en termes aussi on
pourrait presque dire de dumping parce
un réseau social sympa qui a pas de pub
ciblée ça attire beaucoup de gens mais
ça rappelle les méthodes qui ont été
utilisées par la Chine sur des produits
des matières premières rares ou même
maintenant sur des composants
technologiques je prends 100% du marché
je casse la concurrence et après j'en
fais quelques choses d'autres et les
prix remontent et bien moi je veux
savoir où est la valeur où est la
production de valeur qu'elle soit
monétaire fiduciaire ou idéologique ou
politique qu'il y a pour Tik Tok et
aussi pour son pays de référence la
République populaire de Chine je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Nous City pour votre long
exposé
très clairement vous nous l'avez
démontré l'Internet est un terrain
d'affrontement mondial
et on voit très clairement cette guerre
froide de numérique qui s'est désormais
installés donc c'est bien la lutte pour
la domination du monde via l'économie et
surtout la connaissance quand je dis la
connaissance c'est-à-dire les réseaux
sociaux l'information la désinformation
c'est l'accès à certains nombre de
contenus et très clairement on voit vous
l'avez bien expliqué les rivalités entre
les États qui ont su dans les
entreprises ont su construire des des
modèles donc c'est quelque part à
travers cette interdépendance qui est
remise en cause aujourd'hui vous avez
parlé des tricotages à interdépendants
c'est la balkanisation de l'Internet qui
est en route pourriez-vous nous dire
précisément ce qu'est les susceptible
d'entraîner d'un point de vue plus
général d'un point de vue
économique des différentes
interdépendants justement que vous avez
évoqué car c'est tout ce que les
pionniers et les pères de l'Internet
avaient imaginé pouvoir se réaliser un
jour on est à contre-courant de ce qui
était voulu pour être le réseau des des
réseaux donc en quoi ça va redistribuer
les les équilibres dans dans le monde
dans cette
guerre de l'Internet
on voit que l'Europe très clairement est
un enjeu avec son marché profond durable
de 500 plus de 500 millions de de
consommateurs et vous l'avez bien
expliqué avec la question de Huawei des
infrastructures depuis Donald Trump
c'est devenu extrêmement
crucial et c'est Tik Tok aujourd'hui qui
cristallisent
beaucoup de cette de cette problématique
alors s'agissant de la réglementation
européenne pour laquelle je rappelle
Charles Michel
disait il nous faut une réglementation
européenne pour nous situer entre le
modèle business vos américains et le
modèle du Crédit Social chinois on doit
inventer un autre modèle en tout cas une
autre régulation donc le rapporteur vous
a interrogé précisément sur le DSA et le
DMA vous avez souligné que nous avons su
nous doter d'un certain nombre d'outils
de régulation malgré tout j'aimerais
revenir sur le DSA pour lequel
d'ailleurs notre commission des averses
européennes nous a déjà auditionné c'est
bien le texte qui va réguler les
services et les contenus donc Tik Tok
croyez-vous qu'en l'état le texte adopté
permettra sérieusement d'aller mesurer
ce que sont ces algorithmes comment ils
fonctionnent en tout cas leur caractère
opaque et et peu transparent y a-t-il
avec ce texte les moyens
d'accéder vraiment assez assez boîte
noire n'aurait-il pas fallu prendre
d'autres mesures c'est à dire des
expertises indépendantes des évaluations
design plus régulières de ces
plateformes pour avoir dispositif d'une
régulation plus plus efficace voilà
enfin vous avez parlé de l'enjeu de la
relocalisation des données depuis
l'affaire snouda les données produites
par Tik Tok d'après ce que j'ai compris
des utilisateurs américains mais au-delà
de la localisation y a-t-il pas là quand
même la problématique quoi qu'il arrive
de toute façon du traitement de ces
données des logiciels de traitement de
ces données merci de vos réponses
on vous laisse le soin de
vous avez un petit quart d'heure si vous
pouvez réussir à
un petit quart d'heure 20 minutes pardon
madame
faites-moi des grands signes parce que
si l'administrateur me tire pas la
manche je vous en prie vaut mieux qu'on
pose la question en même temps
simplement nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure je voudrais revenir sur le fait
que l'Union européenne est maintenant la
France qui ont suivi les États-Unis et
donc ont interdit Tik Tok en tout cas
ont interdit que leur fonctionnaire
administration utilisent l'application
je voudrais savoir dans quelle mesure
cette décision est-elle de nature à
limiter son influence selon vous est-ce
qu'un ban total est envisageable et
sinon à banc partiel prémunit-il contre
les menaces les plus vives qui
fragilisent la souveraineté nationale
et enfin peut-on craindre via Tik Tok
une attaque géante aussi paralysante que
celle venue de Russie ayant paralysé
l'Estonie en 2007 un état comme celui-ci
vous paraît-il davantage prémuni que le
nôtre en cette matière aujourd'hui je
vous remercie
très bien
extrêmement complet donc je vais essayer
de
d'être aussi d'être aussi précis
possible en commençant peut-être par
non pas par facilité mais mais
effectivement j'ai soulevé le point mais
monsieur tout à l'heure de d'autres
d'autres d'autres États notamment l'Inde
ou la Jordanie qui ont qui ont interdit
l'application donc et qui est qu'est-ce
qui a conduit principalement c'est c'est
état à agir de la sorte dans le contexte
était particulier puisque on était en
plein en pleine compétition qui a qui a
failli déboucher sur des choses
affrontements militaires entre les pays
où
l'enjeu tel qu'il a été formulé par New
Delhi était d'aller bannir une
soixantaine d'applications chinoises sur
sur le territoire indien dans le cas Tik
Tok c'est c'était encore plus sensible
parce que le discours indien à l'époque
en 2019 en 2020 m'était déjà l'accent
sur les risques potentiels pour pour la
jeunesse indienne et c'est ce qu'il y a
d'ailleurs justifié de la part des
autorités jordaniennes donc avec
évidemment une population bien moins
nombreuse comme en Inde la décision
d'aller interdire l'application ce qui
d'ailleurs dans le cas de la Jordanie
aurait dû être temporaire c'est-à-dire
que ce qui avait été formulé par paramas
au départ de dev circonscrit dans le
dans le temps et ça a été prolongé sans
justification politique et là Tik Tok a
demandé tout récemment à demander à
demander des des réponses par rapport à
cette à cette prolongation non justifiée
dans quelle Égypte on en a encore au
stade des discussions parlementaires de
débats assez nourris d'ailleurs et là
encore une fois le le prisme est
vraiment vraiment posé sur sur
l'influence de Tik Tok sur la jeunesse
donc on revoit quand même assez souvent
cette cette donnée revenir qui ne
concerne pas uniquement évidemment les
jeunesses américaines et européennes ce
qui me conduit à un point qui avait été
soulevé
au sujet au sujet finalement de la
question assez large des campagnes
d'influence finalement qui peuvent être
menés par cet acteur
je me distancie peut-être de façon de
façon assez claire de d'attaque par le
bicyber parce qu'en fait avec Tik Tok il
s'agit pas de cet enjeu là mais il
s'agit vraiment d'aller structurer
potentiellement des campagnes influence
sur un long terme et je le répète aussi
non circonscrite à des périodes de crise
politique précise comme la Russie par
exemple a pu a pu les exploiter en
tirant profit de contestation liées à
des à des référendums ou à des élections
par exemple bon ici les campagnes
d'influence en fait de de TikTok n'ont
jamais été démontré clairement comme ça
a dû vous être exposé précédemment
encore une fois
l'idée de l'application se situe assez
en amont il s'agit d'aller dissuader
toutes toutes velléité contestatrice et
pour prendre un exemple récent tirer du
contexte post invasion russe de
l'Ukraine à partir de février 2022
l'application
pas dû se conformer à la loi russe qui a
été réactualisée sur les fake news
mais en fait Tik Tok est allé est allé
au-delà et du jour au lendemain sans
incitation faite par le législateur
russe en fait à couper l'accès à tous
les contenus de l'application qui ne
concernait pas la réussite donc du jour
au lendemain à peu près 95 % des
contenus qui auparavant était
accessibles aux utilisateurs russes de
Tik Tok ont disparu donc il y a eu une
sorte de
comment qualifier devant vous mais mais
de d'anticipation finalement des
desiderata
de certains législateurs et ici en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence la Russie
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est la
resituer dans cette relation bilatérale
sinorus dont on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui et qui sur un plan
technologique et numérique est assez est
assez
est assez nourri je ne sais pas mais
c'est très certainement dirigé là aussi
contre contre cette hégémonie perçue
aussi de la part de la part des acteurs
américains dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure et ça c'est tout à fait
convergent avec et c'est une parenthèse
avec le discours russe sur les
plateformes américaines qui vous
reprenez le fil des déclarations de haut
niveau depuis il y a depuis un an
assimile les plateformes américaines à
des jeux cite à des armées qui nous
tirent dans le dos etc etc donc on a une
vraie une vraie militarisation entre
guillemets du discours au sujet de ces
acteurs technologiques et que ça
concerne pas que Tik Tok ça concerne
évidemment aussi les les gafams pour
pour aller pour aller vite
pour en revenir à cette à cette à cette
notion de campagne d’influence
en mettant l'accent sur sur la jeunesse
comme je pense vous l'avez fait en
partie de durant durant les auditions de
ces commissions d'enquêtes
ce qu'il faut bien bien voir ici c'est
c'est l'affaiblissement
l'affaiblissement des résistances sur
sur le long cours les doctrines
chinoises mettent l'accent sur la guerre
intelligentisée c'était une mauvaise
traduction je n'ai pas je n'ai pas le
bon terme ici devant vous mais l'idée
est d'aller et d'aller détruire la force
productive d'une société pas durement
bien sûr mais sur plusieurs décennies
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
écrit noir sur blanc et ça ça peut être
atteint je cite via des actions directes
sur sur la cognition de l'ennemi sachant
que les stories
écrit noir sur blanc ou dans les dans
les doctrines de sécurité donc militaire
de la Chine donc ça c'est quelque chose
a parlé
exploiter ça justement contre contre
l'adversaire
identifié donc c'est c'est assez c'est
assez
[Musique]
particulier pour le présenter comme
quelque chose étant de bonne guerre tout
à fait d'accord je vous ai interrompu
pardon sur le déroulement je remercie
sur
sur votre question concernant concernant
finalement je la bonne un parti sur sur
l'affaiblissement des démocraties
libérales avec des inquiétudes qui
auraient dû je cite avoir lieu il y a
longtemps effectivement c'est vrai que
c'est
votre institution avait déjà souligné
les risques les risques numériques liés
à la Chine de très longue date donc il y
a les il y a une partie des débats qui
qui n'a pas émergé ces derniers mois aux
dernières années c'est quelque chose
dont on a pris conscience quand même
beaucoup plus façon beaucoup plus
ancienne mais on espense à un moment
charnière ou c'est plutôt l'ensemble en
fait des sociétés
occidentales qui ont pris la mesure en
fait du risque potentiel posé par ses
par ses acteurs et par justement la
volonté politique aussi chinoise d'aller
agir d'aller agir chez l'adversaire par
ce biais par ce biais numérique
donc affaiblissement oui et encore une
fois au long cours donc là je j'aurais
peut-être un effort de temporalité
exprimée devant vous il ne faut pas
attendre de conséquences à très court
terme ou à court terme mais vraiment sur
un sur un temps sur un temps beaucoup
plus long pour pour en revenir à
des enjeux plus
juridiques
économique aussi dans la perspective
européenne c'est vrai que le le DSA je
l'aborder rapidement mais le les comment
dirais les dispositions
du document peuvent
sembler satisfaits au premier regard ce
qui est intéressant de relever c'est
c'est que déjà une partie du débat
américain au sujet du DSA critique le
texte en nous disant que finalement les
dispositions du DSA iront favoriser les
acteurs chinois pour aller simplement en
Europe donc là aussi vous avez un autre
élément de discours de bonne guerre
entre guillemets qui vise qui vise aussi
à peut-être aussi aller affaiblir
finalement certaines dispositions du du
texte du texte européen et je vous
rejoins même sénatrice sur cette idée
d'aller
idéalement en profondeur dans l'examen
des désagorithmes ou d'aller décortiquer
la boîte noire des algorithmes et celui
de Tik Tok est particulièrement sensible
et opaque vous l'avez souligné donc là
vous avez un enjeu je pense très très
politique à aller interroger et c'est
une une donnée qui là aussi a été
anticipé à mon sens par les équipes du
de l'application avec des il me semble
déjà des expertises indépendantes qui
ont qui ont dû être qui ont dû être
relevés ou soulignés pour pour aller
faire ressortir l'innocuité de
l'algorithme mais ça transparence bon
mais là c'est un enjeu je pense tout à
fait prioritaire à mon sens dans la
poursuite de de cet examen
en matière de
en matière de de d'effet d'échelle vous
avez souligné je crois mais la satrice
l'idée d'être en mesure d'agir ou pas
sur 2 millions de milliards pardon
d'utilisateurs et ce qui n'est pas trop
tard et est-ce que finalement le temps
le temps politique joue un autre faveur
la question est extrêmement délicate
évidemment parce que effectivement on a
affaire un réseau j'ai souligné qui a
une croissance extrêmement rapide on est
passé de 700 millions d'utilisateurs en
2020 à un anniversaire trois ans plus
tard ce qui est une croissance
absolument inédite comparée aux autres
plateformes que que j'ai évoqué
précédemment donc là vous avez à nouveau
cette difficulté d'aller à la remorque
finalement de cette de cet acteur qui
qui évolue qui évolue beaucoup
profondément en très peu de temps donc
cette capacité d'action j'aurais
tendance à rester à rester à rester
optimiste devant vous mais c'est vrai
que le
caractère transformiste finalement de la
société qui a racheté différents acteurs
avant son son exportation
international finalement mérite mérite
justement qu'on reste voilà à cette
mesure sur le projet le projet Clover je
l'avais abordé en parallèle en parallèle
d'un propos sur le projet Texas ou là
finalement assez peu assez peu
d'éléments peuvent être relevés
aujourd'hui si ce n'est et vous l'avez
vu des projets d'implantation de data
center à la fois en Irlande et en
Norvège j'ai mentionné la Norvège dans
un cadre particulier et un peu trivial
certes mais le calirlande est toujours
intéressant dans la mesure où cette état
au sein l'Union européenne c'est
toujours c'est toujours démarqué de
certains efforts de solidarité à la fois
en matière de fiscalité numérique et de
respect des règles concurrents etc avec
des affaires qui ont qui ont défrayé la
chronique ces dernières ces dernières
années et je relève simplement que la
Norvège ne fait pas partie de l'Union
européenne malgré des accords
d'associations évidemment anciens et
étroit mais formellement on en fait pas
partie donc ça pose aussi question
justement sur cette politique
communautaire de Tik Tok
dans sa dans sa stratégie
j'ai peut-être m'arrêter là en espérant
avoir répondu à l'essentiel des
questionnements y a-t-il des questions
qui restent même
une question que j'avais oublié poser
parce que vous avez parlé des la classe
politique aux États-Unis
en faisant un peu le destin Go entre les
démocrates et les républicains
semblent-ils ou les démocrates
chercheraient à profiter de cette
occasion de TikTok pour
légiférer sur l'ensemble des plateformes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus
et dans la foulée peut-être essayer de
préciser la réponse à la question de
Monsieur gatelin sur le l'interrogation
sur le modèle économique
avec le micro par vous répondre
c'est vrai que c'est ces dernières
semaines des derniers mois les
propositions des deux camps républicains
démocrate ont été ont été assez nourris
certaines ont été extrêmement résolus
je pense notamment notamment en
proposition du sénateur marcoroubio ou
Marc Warner républicain qui
m'a courbure républicain qui qui ont qui
situe dans une longue tradition
justement de de comment dirais-je
de
de régulation de projet évidemment très
très politique par rapport par rapport à
cette émergence des organisateurs
chinois ce projet démocrate en fait il a
il a émergé il y a quelques semaines
dans cette idée qui qui était déjà
présente chez certaines des figures de
l'établissement politique américain
chez San figure qui qui pour certaines
sont entités d'ailleurs l'administration
je pense notamment à timoo
qui qui portait déjà ce type ce type de
de législation autour d'une prise en
compte des de tous les effets délétères
des plateformes des plateformes
numériques et pas seulement en se
focalisant sur sur tel ou tel acteur
c'est pas seulement Tik Tok mais c'est
aussi un certain moment pu être pu être
Facebook donc le groupe meta donc c'est
un point intéressant parce qu'en fait
cette lecture globale aux États-Unis on
l'a on l'a assez rarement eu donc ça
mérite d'être souligné et peut-être et
peut-être possiblement d'aller aussi
aussi interagir avec vos homologues vos
homologues du Congrès mais mais pour le
coup ça s'aviserait à prendre en compte
à prendre en compte l'entièreté des des
risques des risques ma formationnels
essentiellement justement porté par
portée par ces par ses usages et ça
c'est aussi en lien avec des
pneumatiques très
très nationales pour le coup lié aussi à
l'influence de de certains de certains
influence au rôle et l'influence de
certains de ses réseaux dans dans des
affaires de Thury de masse aux
Etats-Unis etc donc vous avez aussi une
à des centrales par rapport par rapport
à la stricte question chinoise donc
c'est aussi je pense intéressant de le
relever et sur le modèle ce fameux
modèle économique de Tik Tok alors là
c'est une question extrêmement
extrêmement délicate parce qu'en fait
c'est ce qui a été relevé jusqu'à
présent comme étant la force principale
de Tik Tok c'est la puissance de son
algorithme et pas effectivement pas le
pari fait sur la c'était ciblée ou
d'autres ou d'autres atouts ou d'autres
types d'avantages comparatifs ce qui a
été ce qui a été pratiqué dès le départ
par TikTok ça a été un appui sur sur des
relais
issus du monde des du monde des arts
enfin de la musique essentiellement et
aussi du sport des des contrats ont été
noués notamment aux États-Unis avec des
figures du du basket ou de la musique en
fait sur sur place et ce qui ont permis
ensuite ce qui a permis au réseau à Tik
Tok d'aller engranger très massivement
utilisateurs mais sur le modèle
économique en tant que tel et sur
évidemment la croissance de cet acteur
là j'aurais j'aurais moins
d'informations à relever parce que ça
reste effectivement effectivement assez
assez opaque encore aujourd'hui ce qui
ce qui avalise en fait votre votre
hypothèse sur sur finalement une part
plus grande à accorder à accorder au
projet
pas d'autres questions non c'est bien je
pense qu'on a fait le tour mais écoutez
Monsieur Merci beaucoup pour pour vos
éclairages devant la commission merci à
vous